the Game of Thrones guys are getting out
of the galaxy far far away David Benioff
and DB Weiss best known for creating and
showrunning game of Thrones have exited
Lucasfilm and their planned Star Wars
trilogy the pair were slated to write
and direct three films that would have
served as the next chapter in the Star
Wars franchise following the launch of
the rise of Skywalker the final
installment in the nine film Skywalker
saga Benioff and Weiss revealed in a
statement why they are no longer making
their Star Wars trilogy they are simply
too busy working on projects for Netflix
in August 2019 it was reported that the
duo had inked a massive five-year deal
believed to be worth as much as 300
million dollars with the streaming giant
to create new television series and
original movies no details on Benioff
and Weiss as Netflix shows and films
have been revealed as of the making of
this video but it seems clear that they
may be more invested in those projects
than in their three Star Wars films
still the joint statement that Benioff
and Weiss provided to Deadline alongside
the announcement indicates that their
decision to depart from the Star Wars
universe had no ill intent and that the
move wasn't motivated by any bad blood
or behind-the-scenes troubles it read in
part we love Star Wars when George Lucas
built it he built us - getting to talk
about Star Wars with him and the current
Star Wars team was the thrill of a
lifetime and we will always be indebted
to the saga that changed everything
there are only so many hours in the day
and we felt we could not do justice to
both Star Wars and our Netflix projects
so we are regretfully stepping away
Lucasfilm president Kathleen Kennedy
echoed Benioff and Weiss his sentiments
in a statement of her own writing David
Benioff and Dan Weiss are incredible
storytellers we hope to include them in
the journey forward when they are able
to step away from their busy schedule to
focus on Star Wars judging by the
remarks Veni off Weiss and Kennedy made
it appears that everything is pretty
peachy keen between the creatives and
the studio
however some Thrones fans have begun
theorizing that perhaps this isn't the
entire truth and that lucasville may
have actually fired Benioff and Weiss
over their polarizing handling of the
final season of Game of Thrones
my heart is broken don't touch me
this of course is all just speculation
the upside of all of this is that the
Star Wars franchise will be just fine
without Benioff and Weiss on board
Lucasfilm is far smarter than to have
the future success of the entire film
series hinge on the enduring commitment
of two people plus the studio has plenty
of time to get its proverbial Tie
Fighters in a row and decide who should
take the reins on the franchise moving
forward as the Star Wars films we'll be
taking a brief hiatus following the
December 20th premiere of the rise of
Skywalker it's believed that the break
will last three years given that the
first of Benioff and Weiss as three Star
Wars installments was expected to hit
cinemas sometime in 2022 one might
assume that Lucasfilm would have to
delay the franchise return by a year or
two to make up for the loss of Benioff
and Weiss and creative shakeups that
will ensue but don't forget that the
studio has two big-name movie makers
already working on projects of their own
creatives who are more than capable of
taking the place of Benioff and Weiss
both the last Jedi writer director Rian
Johnson and Marvel Studios chief
creative officer Kevin Feige are set to
create their own additions to the Star
Wars universe with Johnson making his
own trilogy and Feige onboard to produce
one movie it seems most plausible that
Lucasfilm will effectively replace
Benioff and Weiss as trilogy with
Johnston's though there's no way to know
what the studio will do at this point in
time either way the future of Star Wars
still looks bright check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about Star Wars are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the belts so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]